those of you who can't read the number  on my back I'm John Wayne movie actor I  work with my clothes on who horses are  rough on your legs  and on your elsewhere when you worked in  front of as many cameras as I have you  build up a healthy respect for that guy  behind the lens who squints through his  finder moves you over a couple of feet  and then puts pure art on the film I'm  talking about our cinematographers and  it's my real deep down pleasure to read  the list of men nominated this year for  the best achievement cinematography  Arthur Ibbotson friend days  Charles B Lang for Bob Carol Ted malice  Conrad Hall for Butch Cassidy and the  Sundance Kid late Harry straddling for  Hello Dolly and Daniel feft  for Maroon congratulations all and let's  see whose name is in the envelope the  winner is Conrad hall  I'd like to thank Catherine she wanted  me to have it in all of you